the Joe Rogan experience do you like the
whole point scoring format thing do you
think just it's a good added element I
like it I like it because and not
necessarily because it changes how
people's fight people fight fighting in
this organization I believe you kind of
you a little more loose you know I mean
you you show up and you know you have to
win you try to win and you try to win if
you don't just try to get the W you know
they're there there's a lot of fights
sometimes when it's like you're on the
bubble and it's like you're fighting
very cautious you know I feel like with
this rule set you get to just be
yourself out there you ever you always
want to win so you're always going to
fight to win but you don't necessarily
change your style to play again play the
rules you just go you're just gonna
fight the way you fight hmm the only
thing that concerns me is that it's a
little complicated like the pay
attention to all the for the fans yeah
the points and all that just so I
understand why you would say that but if
you're watching the broadcast like you
know you got me Sean Randy behind the
desk and we're trying to keep people
updated with the points and how that
works and and it's it's really not that
hard
whoo Sean Sean O'Connell also he's doing
commentary so he's doing commentary he
was a radio guy right yeah he was a
radio guy for not serious like a sports
radio car and he crazy
yeah good for him yeah he's a
millionaire divertor is a million and
he's diversified his portfolio and he
retired he retired from fighting and now
he's in the booth resumes and he's I
think he's a pretty good play by play
guy especially as a former fighter not a
lot of play-by-play guys are former
fighters yeah that's right it's usually
color and he he fought well in the UFC -
he's a tough guy yeah I mean and and
it's weird I always make fun of him I
always tell him like hey you fight like
Homer Simpson but you fight IQ is higher
because he takes so many shots man he
just like stands in front of you and
just trades punches but like like he had
to use his brain to beat Vinny you know
what I mean yeah um this is Vinny takes
you down gets on top he's got he's gonna
grind and grind himself to submission
yeah but um with Sean he was you know he
backed away from from the because all of
his other fights all season where the
Homer Simpson fight you know like he got
hit sometimes but he just came back and
bombed on you and and knocked everybody
out he lost every first round that he
fought one of them he lost the entire
fight but um every other fight that he
fought he lost the first round and then
came back in and just just balling on
guys even with Vinny he lost the first
round you know
[Applause]